INSTRUCTOR: Hello, visitors.
We are going to do a Cairn
reveal for Cairn number
2, the chart types.
And this will be
a chance for you
to review some of the
answers and hopefully refresh
your skills.
You were first asked to connect
to the data source, which
I provided the Hollywood's
most profitable story CSV file.
And you were asked to
create a bar chart showing
some of profitability
by lead studio
to answer which studio had
the third highest profit.
So if we jump to
my toolbox file,
you'll see here that I've
put profitability on columns
and default aggregate is sum.
And then I've added
lead studio two rows.
And then I just did
a descending sort
so I could quickly see that
Warner Brothers was my third.
So let's head back to
that presentation file.
And you can see that indeed,
Warner Brothers was that third.
OK.
Moving on to the
second question,
now we're going to create
a scatter plot showing
that relationship between
average audience score
and average worldwide gross.
Now, hopefully you caught
on to the word average,
because remember the
default aggregation is sum.
So you'd have to change that.
And then you are looking for
the genre with the highest
and popularity but second.
And I think I have the
word popularity twice,
so I need to check that
into audience score.
So here I've put
in audience score.
To change that aggregation, you
just drop down to this measure
and you go from
sum until average
and then you have
worldwide gross
and you change that
one also to average.
And then you can add
genre onto detail.
So I take genre.
I've only got one.
I bring genre onto
detail, and now I
can see that I have
a top performer here
in terms of genre, but
it's second to fantasy
in terms of audience score.
So animation is
that correct answer.
All right.
The next one is a question
about scatterplots,
and they require at least one
measure on the columns shelf
and at least one measure
on the rows shelf.
So you can see that
right here, 1 and 1.
OK.
Question number 4, looking
at creating a dual axis
axes to show the lead
studio as a header and some
of profitability and some total
audience score on the dual axis.
OK.
So let's go ahead and jump to
question 3 so you can see that.
So what I did is I put lead
studio along the headers
down here, and then I
brought in profitability.
You can see that right here.
Let me just go
ahead and redo this.
I'll just put that down here.
So I've got lead studio, and
I've got profitability here.
And then I needed
total audience score.
And I'll just go ahead
and place that down here.
And then what I need
to do is I can make
that a dual axis right here.
Now I went ahead and
changed the chart type
so that they could just
look a little bit different.
And I'm going to just
go from a line to a bar.
You can see that's covered here.
So I can actually move
profitability up over here.
Oh, that changed to a line 2.
So let me do--
one of them is a line.
Oh, the way that I can make
that come forward, actually,
is to move--
it's interesting
if I move it here
that I can bring that on top.
So you do that
within the row shelf.
So now here I can
see that I've got
independent-- is that top one.
Now I could change this
line to maybe a circle.
You can see that
right there on top.
So basically, you're
taking those two.
Now, I did not sync the axis.
I didn't synchronize them.
But if I did that, if
I synchronize that,
you could still see that
both of those measures
played out for the independent.
But that wasn't necessary
for this particular question.
OK.
All right.
Jump into there.
Which one stands above the rest?
It was the independent.
Now for the next one.
So after discovering
which studio stands out,
you have your own inquiry where
you're thinking about Paramount,
Sony, and Universal and which
one had the highest audience
score.
So you're going to create a pie
chart with the studio on color,
and then look at audience score
percent on angle with a filter.
We're also going to do a
quick table calculation.
So let's go ahead and
jump to the question
for see what I've done here.
Let's go ahead and
rebuild this here.
So one of the ways that you
can do that is you can do--
let me go back.
All right.
So if I do this
studio and I just
hold down my Control or Command
key and do audience score,
and I have those two
selected, I can actually
go here and select the pie
on Show Me as a quick way.
And then I can go and place--
what was I looking for?
Oh, yeah.
It's looking for
studio on the filters.
And now I can just select.
So I'm going to say none.
And I'm only going to do
Fox, Paramount, and Sony.
I think that's what I had.
So I'll say, OK.
Let me make sure--
oh, Universal,
Paramount, and Sony.
So let me go back here.
I'm going to edit.
Let me actually just
go to show filter
so I can do it right
here on the Fly Fox.
I gotta double
check which one's,
Paramount, Sony, and Universal.
All right.
Paramount not Fox, but Sony.
There we go.
Now I'm going to make
this entire view.
So I can see that I could
even make that larger.
Oops, not that large.
And here I see this
audience score, which
is not what I'm looking for.
I'm going to go right
onto the audience score,
and I'm actually going to
do a quick table calculation
to see percent of total.
And then I'm going to
go back to make sure I'm
compute using lead studio here.
So when I have that I can see
that Universal is that 46.89.
So if I go here,
you can see 46.89
is where we're looking for.
So that took a few things
to do and hopefully you
picked up on that percent of
total quick table calculation.
So how many different categories
should a pie chart have at most?
And the recommended from
Tableau is the number 5.
And now we're going
to use a goal.
We're going to
create a bullet chart
to determine which
genre was able to meet
that some of worldwide gross.
So let's go over
here to question 5.
Now, I already have
year on filter.
But basically, what you'll need
to do is go into the data source
first and drag in production
goals to make that connection.
And that connection
will be on genre
and it should do
it automatically.
Then I'm going to
create a simple table,
calculate a simple bar chart
with worldwide gross sales
and then genre.
Then once I click
on goal, then I
can go to show me and
go to that bullet chart.
Now, if you remember
in the AG, often when
we use show me this
is not the right--
this is not right field line.
So I need to swap
that field line.
So once I swap that, then
the goal will be there.
That's what I want.
And now I can see and
I can even do down.
So I can see that comedy has
greatly exceeded its goal.
These all exceeded their goal.
In fact, everything
but animation did.
But comedy outpaced
everyone else.
So that was the answer on that.
And then using that bullet
chart, we want to see in 2011.
And to get to that, you saw that
I just placed year on filters
and I only selected
2011 and I said, OK.
And then once I did that, I
could see that romance greatly
exceeded.
Animation at this point still
has not exceeded their goal.
Drama has and comedy has not,
but romance has greatly exceeded
and that was that question.
All right.
The last ones are just
questions about chart kinds.
And which of the
following is a good reason
for using a bullet graph?
And it's that idea
of comparison,
the actual to the target.
And the next question
is, what do you
need to create a
histogram in Tableau?
You could have just
gone to Tableau.
Go to the Show Me.
Roll over the
histogram, and you'll
see that one measure
is the answer.
So a single measure is correct.
To create headers
in a visualization
you most likely need?
A dimension is the correct one.
And you could have gone to one
of these previous ones here,
and you would have
seen, oh, lead studio.
That's a dimension.
Then the next one is,
when using a bar chart
with a dimension
on the column shelf
and a measure on the
row shelf, how can you
make a stacked bar chart?
Now, just you know, doesn't
matter if it's on the column,
it's on the rows or
the column shelf,
but you need to add
another dimension
to the color on the marks card.
So let's just go to
the very first one.
And if I bring just
another dimension like film
and I add it to color, then
this is not a good example,
but you can see now I've got
the stacked and I have multiple.
And I could actually put
film onto filters here.
And I could just say none.
And I could just
say a serious man.
That's pretty interesting.
That's probably
going to show one.
So that's not the
best example here.
So maybe I put genre
on to color here.
OK.
And then maybe I bring
genre onto filters.
I say none, but
we'll do animation.
We'll say, OK.
Oh, it looks like Disney,
really outpace the rest.
So anyway, so there's
a lot of different ways
that you can play around
with those chart types.
But to create that stacked one,
you want to put that onto color.
So I think that was the
last question in that Cairn.
Hopefully you are
feeling more confident
regarding your chart
types, and we'll
continue to build your
skills and Tableau.
Happy vising.